hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm mark
Ricci mark Ricci yo you're chip you you
like yeah this leaning in thing about
you huh super relax just relax man right
movie man mark is here yeah man Marcus
yes he was from Canada still is from
Canada and now he lives out here in
California go check out his YouTube
channel wide variety a comedy over there
hey we're gonna check out the trailer
today for what men want which I am 100%
assuming is inspired by the classic Mel
Gibson flick what women want and my
inspired you mean ripped off ripped off
I don't know let's find out doesn't have
this great uh you know title as what
women want kind of rolls off the tongue
better yeah and especially with WWI mmm
mmm movie man mark your I plug I plug
myself to it you're so good at I'm so
[ __ ] bad degree real quick I want to
give a page from the day shout-out to a
woman named Rosa para Rosa para hazard a
si Rosa Parks yeah Rosa Parks
there's a whole bus situation she wants
a Rosa para is one of our top patrons of
all time she is the lady stark of our
patron page
Rosa I want you to know that when people
think when mango what what does a man do
I want it's yo fine-ass Rosa damn girl I
tear that ass up I'm not even gonna let
you try to read my thoughts just hear it
loud and proud just know that you are
one of the sexiest women of all time men
will be constantly you Eve breaking
hearts walking down the street cuz you
are exactly what men want I love you my
dear Wow shout out complete okay well
the taraji P Henson's in this too right
yes wait a circle back
so block already celebration for the big
[Music]
dudes like I'm just a man with no
eyebrows too many keys that's just
Jasmine if you don't count the we knew
peony okay
[Applause]
really whack last night that's what
happens when tequila meets what you
complain about men trying to keep you
down do we have any meetings books
nothing yet because that the private
poker game tonight
this is not a curse
- tennis
[Music]
[Applause]
the lady which is doing at the big boys
table huh
blocking these Falls I'm missing Real
Housewives check finally has a winning
hand my fig in the third person I wonder
if they're hoping that people don't
remember what women want why just
because they're kind of playing it off
as something completely new that's sure
that they're not showing any linkage to
what women want it's not like 20 years
ago a man yeah trying to steer clear
from Mel Gibson I did get that vibe it's
a different audience too yeah it's a
very different it's a different kind of
comedy in general the same setup but I
don't know like there was something
about what woman want and I'm not gonna
spend this whole video comparing it but
with what women want it was about a man
learning the insight of women in a
variety of different ways he kind of
manipulates his way into a lot of things
but then he also learns a lot about
developing a bigger hard to being
Elizabeth like a dude about things and I
really like that movie I think it's
really funny film is we're not gonna be
that this one doesn't seem to really
have the commentary factor no I think
they're just taking the general idea and
yeah and trying to roll with it as
opposed to completely repeat the same
yeah because it seemed like okay oh this
is about a woman trying to learn how to
be amongst men in the workplace and now
she's gonna take this to her advantage
and and start learning to adapt and yeah
there's elements of that here but it
seems like everything's just played for
wacky is that your phone you
unprofessional son of a B I didn't think
it was that popular but I just got two
in a row maybe people are already
following me
no I rely no no one even followed me
well yeah I was watching this I'm like
okay this seems to be like a lot of
wacky jokes a lot of silly stuff going
on but you're gonna call what men won
and and I kind of would have wanted to
see somewhere that like social
commentary and let's face it if you're
gonna do a movie called what men want I
think I think if you do a what women
want to make it pg-13
you're reading the inside of women's
brains I don't know if this column is
gonna sound sexist at all what I'm about
to say but I think if you do what men
want yeah I think it'll work better as a
hard-r comedy yeah especially with
knowing men as a man and knowing how men
usually people we don't know it could be
an hour but I don't you're not getting
that vibe Briana's gonna be some like
slapstick pg-13 yeah yeah January movie
to comedy my tickets but it has a pretty
good cast
oh yeah the cast is great Pete
Davidson's in this future husband of
ariana grande tracy morgan's in this a
guy from Silicon Valley what was his
name come on up here Baghdad I think
they're trying to give it a more of an
ensemble cast cuz you can kind of like I
don't know when you see enough trailers
like me and you probably have this
mindset of the boardroom meeting like
how is this movie finished so they're
like all right we're gonna do a what
women want yeah reimagining but we're
gonna make it for a black audience and
have an ensemble cast to give it a
different vibe yeah I think that's what
they're trying to do here because I mean
what women want is kinda what they're
trying to do it and they could work cuz
I've never been opposed to the reverse
concept of what women want like you
switch genders I've always thought
that's a very appealing and an easy idea
for a film yeah some of these jokes
really landed for me like when Shaq is
like what am I thinking in the third
person
yeah he's play himself isn't he he's
playing so yeah so Jack Tracy Morgan I
smell toast you know like weird jokes
like that worked for me but there are
some jokes here where I'm like I missed
the relationship element those dynamics
this is so obviously barbed from what
woman 1 I feel like there's elements of
what women want that works so well that
I really I could transmit a they easily
can translate here I just don't really
feel that even though the plot point of
you know a guy being able to read
women's minds is unrealistic I thought
what women want treated that in a way ok
what it's the realistic way this would
go down for a guy in a romantic comedy
sense he didn't live in slapstick world
this lives in slapstick world so that
could be a good thing there was a little
bit of slapstick but it seems like
they're elevating it more in this yeah
that's my point it's like it feels so
wacky that none of the characters seem
real
to me like we watched the trailer for
what women want before we watch that
yeah then you see Mel Gibson fall into a
toilet with a toaster yeah and you went
to me later this is a 90's movie clearly
this might have the same kind of mindset
of the 90s slapstick yeah they are
taking that out it's like maybe they're
embracing the ridiculousness of the
concept more or it might hold it back
yeah from being clever and I'm more
relatable and realistic you know guys
seem like exciting I just don't know
okay it looks like they're trying to
bring it to like a new place per se
because honestly like this could work as
a five-minute SNL skit so how do they
extend that into a movie and make it
different from what women want yeah I
guess what's missing for me is the heart
of this movie it's like I'm seeing the
comedy I've seen the hijinks but where's
the heart of the yeah we'll have to see
if it's there okay yeah very well be a
two-hour movie we're just about a jokes
yeah yeah which could be fine the thing
it's like that could be fine and what
women want isn't a classic so I'm not
saying it has to uphold to that I'm just
saying the kind of ingredients of having
like a heart and grounded and more sense
of realism as what is not being
portrayed to me here in this trailer but
at the same time them embracing the
wackiness of this plot could actually
work to its benefit just don't know yet
yeah we'll have to see but it is right
now looks looks decent
it is a January movie so let's not die I
do think an r-rated humor for what men
WOM will work better yeah we'll see if
it wins an Oscar but and especially in
the times that we're living in now with
all the movements I thought like oh what
men want this could be a really edgy
calm I doesn't seem like an edgy comedy
at all I feel like they could have gone
for that that's basically what I'm
trying to say I think they were scared
too
well I don't blame them yeah you have to
play a little yeah they're not trying to
get into the whole deer ride along you
know yeah like if they did go into that
route the whole me to movement kind of
idea yeah you could see this getting a
lot of at least talk on Twitter and
stuff like that which could be good
publicity but I feel like this checks
all the boxes for the type of movie that
this isn't the type of audience that
they're going for they're not trying to
revolutionize you know the comedy there
anything in January comedy and they're
taking from a previous movie that came
out 20 years ago so keep it light yeah
all right guys well what do you think of
what men want my reading way too much
into this let me know below
hey that's what this channels for
is to dissect yeah construct you guys
can't subscribe to the reject nation
please click that notification Belka
subscribe button suck these days yeah
and you can check us on patreon we got
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
a whole bunch of goodies we offer over
there and more importantly subscribe to
the movie man Mart channel this guy is a
very friendly gentleman funny gentleman
handsome gentleman and also I think
that's an I think you don't more yeah I
don't mean a word no you're gonna top
the three adjectives Gordon yeah and
three is the magic number so let's not
he's got a big dick